proteggo i ponti con box misura ci sono
che la lezione
ma cosa sto vedendo fanno fatto una
barretta energetica per chi si allena
chiamata six pack cruz che a forma di
six pack cioè io non io io io io penso
quella roba lì siamo ritornati dopo un
bordello di tempo si riesce
otto i giapponesi sono molto generiche
come pubblicità secondo me questo è
perché non è un argomento tipo natale
eccetera vediamo produce fuori le cose
[Musica]
così va bene a pensare
questa è quella del rave in piccante ma
ricordo perché se processo mood se te lo
mangi e poi di 29 diventi uno ridiventi
grosso
accendi al potere ok brave cliccando
sapevo rame nel voler il a orecchietta
così che ha detto orecchietta bellissimo
solo ad un palco dei dolci e la prima
cosa che ti vedi mente quando veniva
quelli dolci orecchietta cook ragazzi
quando in casa vi compare una zanzara
sul tavolo
bellissimo di comunque non ho capito una
sega di che cos'era fa niente madonna
che esca l'interminabile non avrei mai è
morta sta morendo locale cade come hanno
fatto a farle fare spazio cose cosa sto
vedendo è arrivata giù alla fine morta
dovrebbe essere proprio l'amica actor
sarà appena visto ma che cosa ho appena
visto ho appena visto una tipa che sarà
un miliardo di scale poi cade riesce a
rotolare per quel miliardo di scala riva
fino alla fine pena di escorazioni
faccia arriva al tipo alla fine poi dice
una cosa incomprensibile in giapponese
ok non credo di aver capito una sega
digon visto alla fine la pubblicità di
caramelle andiamo avanti ragazzi ho
visto molto richiesta non ha segnato ma
di melo mentre sei su un pedalò un po
più umile va bene lo stesso quando eri
al mare chieregato hamas e potete
prendere il pedalò lei mi rispondeva no
due minuti dopo
[Musica]
rimane rami ma morì di tumore
andiamo avanti
guarda lo guardo alla fine guardare alla
fine guardate il gatto alla fine come si
muove e scusate il fire vai io in
discoteca questa questa si preannuncia
ottima va bene quello che hai detto
esatto mario scheiber di vista mettimi
la faccia dentro c'è l'italia mila
faccia quelli sani fifa non possibile
metti mela dentro cosa diavolo sta
facendo della mia vita
[Musica]
gamberi panini ai gamberi è un subway
coi gamberi e bagarre sangue rosa vuoi
davvero ci ho giocato ci credo solo fino
ai rosa poi quindi scavo preso
fantastico beh ho azzeccato della subway
sono caramelle comunque ragazzi la
maggior parte delle pubblicità
giapponesi sono caramel increa fateci
caso c'è o telefonia o alimenti e per la
maggiore sono caramelle sempre così
telefonia caramelle ramen sempre quelle
sono incredibile questo è sembrato di da
mascotte non mi ricordo mai che scooter
ok si faceva così no pretese lì con noi
va bene ma va con box misura di sono
calata nessuna ma cosa sta cambiando i
russi avessero street hanno fatto hanno
fatto hanno fatto una barretta
energetica per chi si allena chiamata
six pack cruz che a forma di six back
cioè io non io io io io tutto norma
tutto normale cosa ci dovrebbe essere di
strane in pubblicità
la velocità come un altro terminator a
non strike a cui i cittadini
ok non ho capito ma sempre quello
sempre mostra strike
e anche la carta igienica deodorati
deodorante per il bagno era o il
deodorante la carta igienica il
deodorante per sbaglio c'è uno chef
cristiano che c'è allora c'è uno che
entra nell'agenzia pubblicitaria
konichiwa abbiamo bisogno di
pubblicizzare il deodorante per il bagno
che penso vi questo giappone e ha tirato
fuori questa cosa io lo compro io vi
dico solo che appena la torino con
abruzzo per cui solo per l'idea cenone
dai ce l'ha nel quadro ragazza le il
quad ai ragazzi incredibile a una ma una
macchina acquista di una macchina
finalmente cosa vedo lockheed sveltato
bellissima la patente per
[Musica]
la donna che sia fortissimo non ho
capito cosa c'entra il ping pong per
quanto vorrei parlare il giapponese e
non trova gesti un cornetto così di te
lo switch è pokémon world
poi la ford c'è proprio sguardo pokemon
figlia no fanno l'upgrade di più di poca
no finché non ci arrivano bellissimo tra
l'altro si veni veni vidi
pokémon news ore dopo il pokemon e lo
sapevo lo sapevo non solo perché noi
lato illuminata anche la pronuncia
sorrido e riuscire dovunque ragazzi
diabete in giappone assicurato ma che
qualche fottutissime caramelle
sponsorizza ma basta
[Musica]
sai con un color oro
tocco milano albero tagliato la gelatina
lega soddisfacenti nella maniera
incredibile possono jonico un buon umore
e se l'è mangiata pure mamma mia
fantastico come questa qua ragazzi la
copertina di kill bill 3 secondo me sono
un sacco di soldi studi
farà visita nell'isola
solo
particolari mediamente one piece non
sembra proprio la bifora panico ricerche
mondo sempre rispettato
quando ride ma non ho capito il senso
signori questa è stata proprio viso come
puntata le più recenti in assoluto
perché le altre ho pescato indietro
queste sono abbastanza recenti vini
spero vi sia piaciuto a meani che io
guarderei questo tutto il giorno cioè
senza neanche sanno spiegare però dovete
dargli tornare in giappone i ragazzi di
guardare questo mi fa impazzire
quindi non vedo veramente l'ora spero
che il tempo passi velocemente perché
dopo un po questo lontano dal giappone
vagina astinenza ormai vi giuro non so
nella mia vita sono veramente contento
di aver fatto questo viaggio questi
viaggi fatelo se vi capita una volta
nella vita
se dovete scegliere dove voglio andar
giappone subito neanche lo dovete
mettere andate tutto così c'è la gente
vestita da limonata finissimo provvede
sia piaciuto ragazzi iscritti al canale
schiacciate campanellina vicino al tas
iscriviti che serve per rimandare la
tensione video che escono enel come
sembra che suoli inceneriamo a un posto
video bello ragazzi
[Musica]